welcome to another episode of not too
deep I'm your host grace and Helbig the
first I am excited about this episode
one because Chelsea Handler is here and
- because I didn't [ __ ] my actual pants
during this interview because I was so
nervous excited inspired scared just
every possible feeling all at the same
time to experience this interview with
her she's got a new book out called life
will be the death of me
life will be the death of me and it's a
brand new kind of Chelsea I think she's
having an adult puberty right now and
it's so fun to talk to her as an adult
to adult I think I went through adult
puberty maybe during this interview
literally I blacked out so I really
can't tell you what happened in what
you're about to hear or watch right now
so enjoy this episode of not too deep
with Chelsea Handler many questions
about Karl oh please I'm ready because I
think people don't how old is he
actually Karl is actually 70 okay cuz I
thought he was ninety nine and a half or
98 and a half thank you for paying close
attention
he's a very I don't know what it is
about rugged handsome he's kind of like
a Sean Connery yeah yeah so I met him
when I I did a ski trip in Park City for
a week okay
in like a month ago and I just decided I
wanted to check out Park City cuz I want
to get a ski house and I want to make
sure we're the right places enjoy you
know as one does as a normal yes you
know a middle-class woman very relatable
and then I met him and he was like you
know he made a joke about aging a year a
day from being around me so we just
decided it was his birthday he's making
you already how he started at 90 we're
not sure because I just decided he was
90 cos he was right now he's got that
very rugged you know he's like an oh
he's like a sailor yeah he cursed at me
and he was like you shut up and I was
like no you shut the [ __ ] up you shut
the [ __ ] up in sexual tension could be
cut with a knife yeah
big time but also an older man that's
capable like that that seems like
physically capable is something about it
is very attractive yeah I mean it's the
same reason why you like are attracted
to your dentist at one point in your
life yeah that you can take care of me
in ways I can't do for myself right now
right I don't obviously no one's
attracted to their dentist but you know
your doctor or your st geologist or in
my case any guy that skis better than me
and is borderline attractive I want to
have sex with there you go that's my
thing have you you so you have skied
when you were younger yeah quite on the
East Coast so it was kind of just from
New Jersey yeah yeah and so I've only
been skiing once in the Poconos when I
was younger my dad had knee problems and
so he just taught us like from afar just
screamed at us on the bunny hill to be
like turn your skis in or out and that
was it and then I went skiing with a guy
I was dating in Maryland as an adult and
it was there's no progression it was no
he was good I was terrible I hated being
bad at something and so I got bad and
was just like I'll be in the lodge was
at that point I could drink in the lodge
and it was a very different skiing
experience theose lee takes it to a
different level with skiing once you're
able to consume alcohol yeah isn't that
the craziest part sports are so much
more enjoyable when you can actually
consume alcohol one I'm so excited that
you're here and taking time to like talk
to us about this cuz this like you're
saying right before we start it feels
like a brand new version of yourself
yeah I mean that sounds you know corny
and annoying but it sounds stupid but
it's real but it's real and it's true
and it's a cliche because it's for a
reason because it happens to so many
people at this age or whatever but yeah
I would say this is a new version of
myself I did a lot of like heavy kind of
emotional lifting and trying to like
figure out why I have such a short fuse
why I can't stick with anything for too
long why everybody annoys me
and through that you know it's made me
like a much calmer more rational not
going a hundred miles an hour like
living my life and actually being a part
of my life rather than being just like a
spectator
well presents right yeah being able to
be present in the moment rather than
continuously thinking about the next
things thing it's what any spiritual
person thinks about but you know la is
it a really tricky gross place for all
of that because you hear the words
gratitude and universe and consciousness
and you just want to stab yourself in
the vagina sometimes like it's enough
yeah it's like come on you know with the
colonics and the meditation and then
those things unfortunately all seem to
get grouped together yeah and like there
and and so you know for instance like I
was listening I was doing I was on the
on a road trip of two years ago and my
friend and I we put on like super-soul
Oprah and she had Bernie Brown and at
the end we listened to it and and then
at the end of it I'm like okay let's
move on to something else
Tony Robbins conference I went in with
skepticism it was peaks and valleys of
like wonderful moments and I think I had
walls up that maybe I should have kind
of deconstructed a little bit more
before I went into that weekend and left
understanding that this works for some
people and like doesn't necessarily
affect other people the same way but the
idea that we're all going into this
weekend like wanting something wanting
to figure out something wanting to
realize where are kind of figuring like
how we relate to people and why we
relate to people which I'm really
excited about this book because I think
that the biggest misconception is that
you have to have it all figured out by
20 or 30 and like to be able to
continuously figure out different phases
of your life and like connect to that
sort of understanding of yourself is
like hugely important and I think a lot
of young women are like I have to have
everything done by 30 right I don't have
everything figured out but I certainly
felt that way yeah 20 sounds like as
long as like you know we were talking
about being in the moment like in my 20s
all I wanted was my career to begin as
soon as my career would begin my my life
would begin yeah this everything else
was just a way to get to where I was
going and
that's what we're all guilty of if we
want results we want and and in your 20s
I think it's fine to feel like that you
know I mean there's a reason why you
kind of wake up in your 30s and 40s and
throughout the rest of your life because
you realized oh wait a second like this
is the only chance I get myself rather
pay more attention to it you know I got
so many of the things that I've wanted
already like the only responsible thing
to do now is to figure out how to be a
better person yeah yeah when you're left
with just yourself like was there a
moment in which you or maybe a series of
moments that made you decide oh I got to
dig a little deeper like I have to kind
of uncover and pull the like curtain
back a little bit more yeah I think just
going through you know your dreams
change all the time and what you're
interested in changes all the time so I
think you get to a place where you're so
excited at your opportunities and you're
so grateful and you're so happy and then
you take like anything else if you're
not you know paying attention you take
it for granted and then those things
annoy you then the people that are like
at your office every day asking you what
your questions start to annoy you not
grateful anymore and then in my personal
fashion I like to just you know go hard
110 miles an hour with everything so I
did my show I did five books and six
years I did six tours while I was doing
a show that was on four nights a week I
would thought I was better and stronger
than everybody like everyone be like
you're pushing yourself you're pushing
yourself I'm like no no I'm German like
and Jewish so a big blessing Jewish
German [ __ ] but no I mean I just
thought oh I can do this I I'm not the
person that needs to go to therapy I'm
just smart for therapy yeah that's my
biggest excite also recently I'm within
the last like year have been doing the
whole mental health deep dive of the
things that I've been avoiding because
I've told myself I can figure this out
behind the scenes cuz I'm very smart and
very astute at like yeah judging
character and also like understanding
psychology and myself
yeah and turns out I'm not I'm not the
best of it when you talk to someone else
that's kind of the better case scenario
and yeah exactly for for me you know I
always everyone you know knows me before
saying the things that nobody said
or being authentic and not having any
filter the problem is as I was being
honest with everybody but myself that's
interested in telling the world the
truth but not ever dealing with my own
injuries and what happened to me as a
child and you know my brother dying at
nine years old and what that does to
your brain and what it does to your like
strength like the reason I feel like I
have to be so tough all the time you
protect yourself with your emotions
those patterns of behavior like to get
somebody who you're paying then tells
you like hey you are lacking in empathy
you're lacking in this like you have no
vulnerability zero and an associating
vulnerability with being a weakling like
sure what you think it's a common
misconception for everyone especially
women were taught to be like dainty and
meek and demure and all of that when
being passionate and confident seems
like it's brash yeah yeah and it feels
like the demure part of you the
sensitive part of you being sensitive is
weakness and that is the biggest
misconception in my like emotional book
that I've learned as an adult
Wow yeah well cuz you said in I listen
like I said to the DAX interview that
you did and it was so great and you said
that for years you never cried in front
of anyone
you cried behind closed doors and I had
the same situation where it's like I
don't want to seem weak I want to seem
strong I want to seem confident I want
to see him like I'm capable of like
achieving and doing certain things and
to have feelings means that you have
your human yeah you have holes that can
be punctured by other people and so it's
you build up this resistance and I think
there's way more strength in like
connecting to that vulnerability then
trying to pretend it doesn't exist and
it's so much like you know when you
think about like when I would hear the
terms about therapy or about getting
serious arrghh meditation even [ __ ]
you know stab me again
because like I couldn't get it I
couldn't get it yeah I get it and my
doctor was like just commit to three
months I'm like three months is
ridiculous I'm not three months of
working with weed meditating every
morning like doing headspace that app I
use oh yeah that man's voice is so
calming yeah Adam I think his name is
yeah yeah
drew I don't know something with an a
yeah and you know committing to three
months and it's like this idea I'm like
three months that's like a pregnancy
today much like the idea that my whole
life is built on impulse and
impulsiveness like so then I did I was
like okay I'm now he goes even more
reason to do it if you can't commit to
something for three months I'm like I
can't commit to anything for any amount
of time and and I did it for three
months and I can't even it's it's
indescribable how much it's in fact it's
not indescribable it's not that amazing
but it's but for you it's impacted my
life in such a great way in terms of
patience in terms of taking my time and
not running through in my day every day
no matter what connecting to your breath
which is such a basic principle you
think you already understand that but
there's so many moments when I'm in
auditions or nervous places that I'm
like just remember to breathe and that
simple thing is so effective for calming
and grounding myself so true it's so
true it's like can you get riled up
you're like just like I you realize
you're anything you like five times a
day I'm like okay and it's also to be
present like if you're taking one big
deep breath you're paying attention to
what you're where you are and being
present yeah and that's helpful to me
too and all these tools that all of a
sudden you find you know like I'm 44 and
I'm like oh [ __ ] so that part of me is
like but you know that's also judging
like that I don't need to judge myself
I'm here now I might as well just enjoy
the party yeah I mean the did you go on
a meditation retreat I try not to do
that now okay been on like I went to a
conference where I spoke with my
psychiatrist because my book is all
about me and my psychiatrist basically
and uncovering my childhood and all that
stuff so I went to a conference where I
was on a panel but I didn't know I'm not
there yet yeah in retreat mode yeah how
I get know my brother my younger brother
just turned 30 last year and he's also
gotten into meditation for anxiety and
depression and that sort of thing that's
been like the main source of like
self-care for him and he decided for his
30th birthday was going on a silent
meditative retreat for ten days and he's
like the funniest
in the world to me and he came back and
I was like how was it like thinking I'm
gonna talk to a completely different
person he's like that's fine I got
really bored like day four and so I just
kind of stuck it out but like didn't
really have any major epiphanies and I
respected that to that it's like you
don't have to like necessarily create
these like big moments for yourself to
try and like push yourself into some
epiphany that might not happen it might
happen like literally the next day when
he wakes up in his apartment in Boston
and all of a sudden like a small bird
triggers something that like opens a
door for him and I like loved that so
much more than him coming back as this
like Elizabeth know very praying yeah
and I think it's all so different you
know I think that's what my my my shrink
was saying like you know you don't
necessarily it's about habituating
yourself like you do the meditation
every morning I do 15 minutes like and
he goes just keep doing it don't wait
for your aha moment just keep doing it
it doesn't matter if you're connected or
if you're thinking about something else
just as a [ __ ] you should obituaries to
me i that clicked for some reason
because i I always you know if I want to
lose five pounds it has to come off
tomorrow I don't have a week I don't
have time like a normal person has time
and why is everything at a ten like you
know actually things go well better
through life if you take you know your
time so for me it's all about just
shutting the [ __ ] up and slowing down
yeah and so now that I'm starting to
like dip my water and me feet into the I
don't know what metaphor or simile I was
about to use but now that I'm getting
into it I'm like oh I know that there's
gonna be so much more that I'm about to
learn yeah I mean it is like like you
said like exercise they you start
conditioning yourself that all of a
sudden endorphins become something you
crave like the meditation the like
patience the silent me time becomes
something that your body needs every day
was there so this book is all about ear
psychiatrist and you kind of delving
into like the whole history of your life
what was the conversation with your
psychiatrist to present this idea to him
yeah yeah I kind of Majan that pitch
meeting say everything we've been
working on I said to him you know
yeah that's great that's really funny
actually I didn't think about it I said
to him I had interviewed him on my last
shape TV show my Netflix show and yeah
and he wasn't so that's the that's the
psychiatrist it's in the Netflix show
yeah he was like I interviewed him about
brain adolescent development how much
damage you can do with drugs and what
age I used to make sure I was in the
business that's a good vetting process I
think yeah anyone going to any
psychiatrist regardless of have a
Netflix show should bet then the exact
same way
and so and he just talked and I just
thought oh I talked to him when I'm
ready if I ever want to talk to someone
I mean you know and so you were this is
someone that the producers like found
for the show they hadn't been already in
a relationship with in okay got it
so then after Trump was elected I had a
really really difficult time with that
and I had just outrage and it wasn't
just that I was depressed or sad or
crazed it was that I couldn't control
like it's all I could think about it was
obsessive and I was I was like oh god I
got it I got to do something what is
going on I couldn't work I couldn't do
anything so I went and started talking
to him for the first three sessions it
was just me bitching about Donald Trump
and Ivanka Trump and their veneers and
how gross they all are and then and then
I real you know once I started to kind
of test the waters with him which was
clearly in retrospect what I was doing
yeah I like speed dating him yeah I was
like are you smarter than me are you
gonna be able to manipulate like what
can I do here and I was like I don't
want to remember my past or my childhood
I just need to be a better person how
can I like calm down and did it and then
you said that you didn't want to talk
about your path yeah I said I'm like my
brother died my mother died loaded
overdo every and I'd go with it don't
worry I'm in here nothing to see ya
buddy he was like uh huh and he never
pushed me he just is like let me just
spin out in front of him like a good
doctor yeah the ones that stay silent
and they're so comfortable with silence
yeah and that you have to fill the
silence and me as an interviewer your
biggest muscle is filling silence
totally and making a joke and not
letting anything get too depressing or
sad so it was like it was basically like
unwrapping everything that I've made a
living doing and the way I've been
operating in my personal life also for
the last 40 years or however long I
don't know 30 years I guess so
he and then finally what we we stand
when we started to get real and talk
about my tea my brother dying in that
event in my life it became obvious that
what Donald Trump represented to me was
the world becoming unbalanced Oh control
and what and it triggered my you know
when my brother died my world became
undone yeah and that was were the only
two touchstones in my life where I had
felt that feeling of everybody's falling
around on the wayside and I'm gonna have
to step up and just like muscle through
this everyone's gonna crumble my dad
when my brother died my dad disappeared
forever he could never recover he was
not the same so I went from being like
the center of my family's attention I
was the youngest of six kids I was cute
blonde and like how they've totally
precocious personality to everyone were
treating and going into their own
corners of grief and I was like whoo and
I had to like you know get it together I
never cried again I was strong I was
like in charge and I became this kind of
fixer and everybody else's problems but
my own well and so taking that through
my entire life and through my adulthood
and pushing through relationships and
being always pushing men away and being
all about single and fused so I'm a
single girl and I'm gonna need a man
it's like it was all about they'll ban
Lyme they went you know they don't
protect you my father didn't protect me
and my brother didn't protect me so men
are the enemy I know I'll do this alone
ya know that's incentive but that's such
an important thing to recognize is like
we're defense mechanisms come from and
and why the one thing I did take away
from the Tony Robbins conference that is
stuck with me forever that like I asked
a lot of friends whenever we get into
deep conversations is he approaches
people and he says who did you want love
from your mother your father growing up
and usually everyone's first answer is
the person that they think didn't give
them love when really if you think about
it it's the other person the other you
know parental figure that you don't
realize is the actual person that you
wanted love from the actual person you
wanted protection from because I use my
parents are divorced and so I used to
say like oh yeah I always wanted for my
dad because he wasn't there but
and I realized as an adult like oh no I
actually wanted it from my mom who was
always very there and emotionally very
loving but like not always present all
the time and so realizing that like
shifted the whole way that I looked at
the way I operate with like female
friendships and like as an adult in the
business industry and like wanting
because my mom was very and is very like
sweet and shy and reserved and like
doesn't really leave South Jersey very
often like I'm gonna go and do
everything that she didn't do when I was
younger and so it's very interesting how
that like one kind of click moment all
of a sudden opens up this brave new
world
and then I burst and you know everything
in your head you're like oh oh [ __ ] okay
and then it's like this vomit of
connections of everything so did you
when when you wrote this did you send it
to your psychiatrist oh sorry we never I
never answered that question we went on
tented thug okay so so yes I started
writing it and I had just you know I
wasn't I wasn't really doing anything
but like trying to campaign for people
on blah blah and I was going to him and
I started writing because I didn't want
to write I wrote five books just banged
him all out and I felt like my integrity
was gone by the end of it like I just
kind of I just kept getting so much
money and I was delivering for a
paycheck instead of writing something
because it came out of me yeah so this
is the first book I mean in five or six
years because I was said I'm not gonna
write another book until I actually have
something to say yeah so I brought yeah
I said I pitched the I mean he's kind of
a well-known guy so that helps because
he's kind of I mean you met him food
he's already exploited of saying you
weren't gonna be the one that forced him
to do that okay what would you would you
be cool if I go I'm totally cool
changing your name in this book but I
really like to tell the truth and you
know I've made a career of telling the
truth now I feel like I have something
that's more like important you know I
mean not just funny and stupid but like
real and important and so if I'm gonna
spend make a career of oversharing why
not over share it's something that can
help people yeah um and so yeah I showed
him a couple chapters and he was like I
love it this is amazing I can't believe
you want to talk about this and
you're gonna reveal all this stuff and I
was like yeah well that's what I do yeah
so so yeah so he's cool with it that's
good is he you're doing a twenty city
tour for the book by the time this
podcast airs the book will have been out
it comes out April nights and people can
pre-order but they can also right now
buy it is he coming on tour with you I
still have to do I have to fill two
shows I have different guests in each
city I'm interviewing me people can get
tickets the lab nation.com and each
ticket does come with a book okay so
yeah we're going to places like
Clearwater Miami all the hot spots
Dallas Austin Houston but he is not on
tour with me I just I don't you know
that's I want the night to be fun yeah
you know I'm so I'm having different
friends and different just people all
across the country and I'm really
excited to go on a tour where I'm this
normal and grounded then you get so the
premise is that you're sitting down
being interviewed by a different guest
in every city yes how does that feel for
someone that's made a living off of
interviewing other people do you have a
hard time feeling like this like you're
the one being talked to and ask
questions no I'm I'm fine being
interviewed I prefer it that's that's
kind of how I bettered my therapist was
like how much does she interviewed me
versus me interviewing her in this
situation right now because I tend to
err on the side of asking her more
questioning questions why do you think
you do that why do people like what is
the trait that makes you interested in
your peer therapist personal life well I
don't get too into her personal life I
try to keep it light enough that's like
kind of triggers her to ask me more
questions I think I'm just used to you
don't you work that muscle so much so
sudden you're like when you're in
conversation with people you want to get
to know them so you use questions as a
means to get to know them and create
like common ground or some sort of like
relatability
between the two people so that's kind of
my go-to constantly which you know works
well for you okay thank you for
explaining to me what a conversation
it two ways straight okay we're gonna
take a really quick break when we get
back we have more questions and we have
a bunch of Internet questions which are
like extremely thoughtful and very sweet
so I'm very excited to get into them so
we'll be right back with more gotcha
deep this episode of not too deep is
brought to you by drop it's a free app
that gives out cash rewards for the
shopping you do every single day link
your debit and credit cards when you
sign up select the stores you shop with
the most and earn points each time you
spend there redeem points for gift cards
the places like Amazon Sephora Lululemon
and many more with drop you can earn and
redeem from brands that are entirely
relevant to you and your preferences
you're able to earn across a number of
brands so you can acuminate you can a
queue accumulate is the way to say that
words accumulating points quickly
especially since the brand's you're
earning points from are the ones you
spend with every day it's easy to link
your cards and then earn points whenever
you spend the app works in the
background to recognize your
transactions and reward you for those
purchases every time and for a limited
time you can head to the App Store or
Google Play and sign up for drop using
my code grace grac and you'll receive a
$10 Starbucks gift card right away make
sure you link a debit or credit card to
the app when you sign up to redeem your
support for today's show comes from Koko
topia after a long day it's nice to
unwind and enjoy some me time and what
better way to do that with them with a
delicious dark chocolate truffle from
coke Autopia
now you can indulge in delicious
chocolate without the sacrifice of
calories because the dark chocolate
truffle is only 40 calories you heard me
40 calories which is 45 percent fewer
calories than lint who dragged them plus
it has less fat and less sugar too it's
the perfect treat after a meal during a
girl's weekend gathering or even paired
with a glass of wine ready to treat
yourself visit coke Autopia dot-com and
enter promo code grace at checkout to
get 50% off your first order make sure
you type the code in all caps
Cocco topia co co t.o.p I a comm and
enter code grace GAC II in all caps at
checkout and get 50% off your first
order indulge without the guilt we're
back
how long you said this book was the most
fulfilling thing for you to write versus
the other books what has been your
experience because there are so many
questions about like the transition from
doing you know pop culture TV to wanting
to actually like make a impact in the
world in like a more substantial way
yeah what what what's that journey been
like for you I hate the word journey but
what I did - I hate that [ __ ] word
well it's because of the Batchelor that
we hate it
yes journey I have to take myself
falling in love with them we have to
think of a new word for journey I don't
know what the enemy report reject I
don't know I gotta find some what's your
experience in that time period like from
show to show to show
yeah well I just again get really you
know I burn out I you're workaholic yeah
I work a lot and then I get I'm like oh
I don't want to do this anymore it's
like I learn how to do something and
then I'm bored with it yeah then I want
to reinvent whatever I'm doing and I
think you know Chelsea that was a great
experience it was so much fun it was
like being in a fraternity house yeah a
good one I know we just had a fun time
when we were a bunch of big kids being
silly and eventually I just was like all
right I'm done with this this is old I
was on II I didn't really give a [ __ ]
but I think that's also like admirable
to know when you're done with something
because I think a lot of people stay
with the fear that they don't know what
the alternative is like the fear of the
unknown of leaving something that is
consistent and safe and versus trying
something else that they don't know if
it'll work it's hard for a lot of people
yeah it is I mean it's you know it
wasn't hard for at that time because I
was just so over it yeah I chose eight
years or something
like that I was like it's enough I don't
want to be doing the same thing every
eight years I wanted to change so I did
that then I kind of like thought I was
gonna travel I did I went for like a
year away I went to another country got
a house started a thing there so that I
have like a retirement place it's great
in Spain so that was fun Spain why Spain
just because it's another country is fun
we had to it's just I just fell in love
with this place that we were visiting
and I was like oh my god we got to get a
house and then I don't know who we are
it's just me but so then I did so I have
this beautiful house in Spain that I
don't spend any time at that I always
look to is like another thing looking
for the future like the future is now I
got to go but I did that and then oh and
then I started with Netflix and I wanted
to do documentaries cuz I just like I
needed to do something outside of my
comfort zone and that was really really
gratifying and I loved it and then I did
my show there for two years and I just
was not that into being on a date like
that it wasn't a daily show it we it was
it was a Netflix his first show so it
went from I think it was three episodes
a week and then we reduced it to one
Episode a week because of the viewing
patterns on you know it's just all it
was such a learning experience but it
was like okay after the election I was
like we need to get focused yeah I need
to be focused and I kind of lost my mind
a bit and I just asked Netflix if I
could go back to doing the documentaries
and so I just filmed one on white
privilege okay and I just watched the
racism one you did I was like 2016 which
is just I think you have a great style
of interview with people where you you
are genuinely curious for good or bad
reasons about what people's like
intentions are which i think is as a
comedian it's probably pretty easy to
insert your opinions on certain things
and to hold back and allow someone to
talk and just let them explain
themselves without a full reaction I'm
sure was like hard to do at times it's a
great exercise though because you know
we become comedians because we want to
be on stage with a microphone where no
one else is allowed to talk yeah yeah
and like think about it you know like
when I think about that it's like that's
the last place I need to be
his on a stage with a microphone and no
one else is allowed to speak yeah they
just did one on white privilege yeah I
did one on white privilege so I'm gonna
do be promoting my book doing my book
tour and then I am going to probably the
documentary will come out right at the
end of summer or in the fall and then
while I'll promote that that's super
cool yeah and you know that's pretty
much it and just trying to become a
great skier well I think you do have
this wonderful balance of work and play
which I admire very much it's like a
memory and I you know really kind of
that's a big philosophy for us we always
say when we're in long shoot days we
kind of chant our mantra is hot showers
cold martinis at the end of the day yeah
and so we like cross our fingers for and
like reward ourselves like we're dogs
that are getting treats at the end of
the day that's how we operate and I
think that that's a really great thing
this shows like yeah this is the hobbies
I like this is how I spend my free time
this is how I like clear my mind and
then get back into working where did you
guys travel for the documentary we went
to Georgia because we it was during the
right before the midterm so we went down
there to talk about the you know black
voters matter and all the voting
suppression and then we went to
Mississippi to that lynching Museum we
interviewed a lot of really fascinating
people my ex-boyfriend from high school
is black and we found him I hadn't seen
him since I graduated from high school
in the DAX podcast yeah yeah right this
is also something I don't know if I
could do but you like to challenge
yourself to experience things firsthand
on camera I am able to do better things
on camera yes that I can't that I would
never do in real life
really that to me I can't relate to and
I fundamentally understand like that
that works for you but I cannot relate
to that as a human I think it would be
too paralyzed by the potential bad that
could happen it's so funny because I
think of the camera AI like to share
like with people like I like to show my
experience so that like when I did
ayahuasca on one of my documentary yeah
it looks like I've never had more people
ask me about oh my god people are so
fascinated with that subject matter and
I don't have a problem with doing any
drug so I was like great let me do it
but it resonated with people and you
know it got people talking about it and
and doing it
it also demystifies it a little bit I
think is what creates like negative
connotations for people is that they
have they don't know they've never seen
it happen so being able to watch someone
experience it firsthand like actually
quantifies like the good or bad of it
for them right yeah I think so and I
also think you know like there's safety
in a camera I feel like okay this is all
documented I got all the right people
around me nothing too bad could happen
I'm protected yes oh that's so
interesting
is there a topic or a show idea that you
haven't explored yet that's kind of
something that in the future is
interesting yeah I think you know I mean
this is about white privilege this
documentary it's at my my own
specifically and it's just a one-off
this is a full-length feature document
yeah yeah so it's just one this is gonna
grab a marker here so yeah we're I'm
gonna sign and uh and so I'm gonna do
that know what I'm gonna do after that
yes I want to do more Chelsea does I
want to get more childlike serious like
that like things that are just like you
know get try and get really good at a
sport you know you like Ament those
kinds of shows and have fun I want
everything to be experiential and I love
to travel so when I can combine those
two things and get paid then that'll be
that's the dream that's it that's how
Marie and I started the Travel Show that
we had that was short-lived was just we
want to get paid to travel together
since we did it so much anyway yeah and
how do we make this an experiential
journey for young people that are
interested in travel to places that they
might have never been before
is there a topic for Chelsea does that
hasn't been explored yet uh sorry to
make you repeat the same question
because I there's well one because
10,000 of our Twitter questions that
we've gotten asked are about is there
gonna be more Chelsea does because
people yes usually aligned with it so
much I think everything I mean for
everything from like being a doula to
you know trying to learn karate just
things that are outside of my comfort
zone you know learning how to windsurf
like my friend has this kitesurfing camp
and he's like why don't we just film you
trying to learn how to kite surf for a
week and we could sell that as a special
I'm like don't joke around because we
will like I will do that
but like a series I'm gonna I think the
next TV series I do will be adventurous
and it will be challenging and it will
be like me going to you know wherever to
you know Japan and skiing with pros or
doing you know something like that I
don't know how to do is there anything
that you draw the line at it's like I'll
never do that like I won't swim with
sharks I mean that's the thing that is
very very terrifying to me I have that
person aches for snakes yes with sharks
but or swam or swum I definitely did not
swim with sharks ah yeah snakes are a
real I I can't get past it
no no no they don't have legs but they
move so fast and I don't understand it
and they're trying they're now swimming
so that's also another reason to stay
out of the [ __ ] yeah they've [ __ ]
on all different terrains and they got
to choose a lane and I would just like
to know you had a baby yeah yeah yeah
she's uh it is really starved for
attention there oh okay a lot of people
want to know this to people that are new
or curious because you did ayahuasca on
the show but people that are newer
curious to trying marijuana for the
first time because there's a lot of I
think because it's being legalized in
different areas a lot of young people
are like cure I'm for myself I didn't
start smoking to like way later in life
because I was always so paranoid that it
would make me paranoid which is what it
did when I first started smoking and so
there's a lot of kids that are just like
I don't know what to do with this do you
have any advice yes first of all there's
I'm coming out with my own line of weed
in the summer are you really yes and ice
could partner with NorCal and we are
creating a line but to reintroduce
people to the met cannabis space because
now but you don't have to wait for my
line to come out because at any of these
stores now then are legalized in the
states that have you know that you're
able to there are so many educational
components it's not about taking a
cookie like it was ten years ago and
being blotted faced out in your bathroom
you know what I mean like it's it's
about taking the edge off it's about
like making it an experience a little
bit more up or you know a little bit
more sparkly it's not about being out of
your mind I mean there's weed for that
too but with micro dosing yeah the two
point five milligrams the five
milligrams like you're safe with that
amount of weed in your system so when
you're going to reintroduce yourself
talk to the people at the store and find
like tell them you're a beginner yeah
want you in the industry they're gonna
make sure you're safe and so my line is
going to be about women and empowering
and embolden women to embrace weed the
way guys do guys don't just get to have
it we get to have it oh that's so cool
how long has this been in the works for
about six months oh wow yeah I've been
developing and pitch fit getting the
flavors and the vape I mean I've been a
high for the last like year and a half
with because of weed yeah because I did
such a deep dive to see how it affects
you in the morning to see because some
people have to deal with anxiety for me
it was sleeping I don't want to take
sleeping pills anymore no I'm yeah I'm
with you that that's become what I use
weed for is to help me fall asleep at
night because that my active brain just
doesn't shut off right and I know like
we between all of my friends I mean I've
prescribed I'm like okay you need a
gummy you need a chocolate blueberry
you need a pharmacist like I can tell by
your personality I mean my pharmacologic
my pharmacological background is really
coming into play that's amazing what is
this been announced what now it has it
yet I can't announce it yet because it's
a parent trademarked gotcha gotcha
gotcha but that's very exciting yeah I
think something that is really necessary
because we're so quick especially a
psychiatrist to kind of like pump pills
into our system for anxiety and things
like that when I think there's a much
like safer more regulated substance that
people can get behind once they like you
said educate themselves that aren't
afraid to ask questions I think that's
the biggest hurdle especially for myself
is like showing weakness and being like
I don't know what I'm talking about I'm
afraid to ask someone else about this
because I don't know and I should know
but I'm very excited for women weed for
women yes very cool what were you most
surprised about in getting into therapy
like if you had to tell your younger
self
something that your older self knows now
is there like one major thing since
you've been doing this kind of emotional
deep dive I think just like there's no
shortcut through your grief or like your
injury whatever your injury was mhm a
there's no shortcut so the more you go
around it and the more you deflect it
the bigger the crash is going to be when
it comes mmm so like you have to address
pain you have to address grief and if
you don't know it's just it doesn't ever
go away yeah so the quickest way is
through it not around it I would say and
the other thing is that I for so long
thought oh I have a TV show with my name
in it I have booked the the Touma it's
too narcissistic yeah to go to therapy I
don't I wasn't raped it wasn't that bad
right there like I can't pinpoint one
source of trauma that could cause pain
for me right it wasn't it wasn't I
didn't think brother dying was enough
and the thing I would say to anybody is
that your pain is enough mm-hmm you
deserve to deal with it and you it
doesn't matter what degree of injury you
have or if your brother died or you were
molested or whatever the thing was it's
like you need to sort it out in order to
get to your future faster and the future
meaning free of all that yeah I think
that's yeah I've never really heard it
put that way but that your pain is valid
like you're regardless of whatever level
you're at or whatever experience caused
it that the way you feel is still valid
right yeah I think that's super huge
well in that very deep note on not too
deep we're gonna take one more quick
break and then we're gonna get back with
Twitter questions we'll be right back
with more deep
[Music]
to this episode of not too deep is
brought to you by bareMinerals creators
of clean beauty purity in formulation
and uncompromising performance have
always been the guiding principles of
bareMinerals because they believe that
makeup and skin care should make your
skin better not just better looking this
has been bare minerals philosophy since
they began the clean beauty revolution
in 1995 with dear best-selling original
foundation which offers creamy
lightweight buildable coverage that's
naturally luminous the clear formula is
made with only 5 good for skin
ingredients all minerals including
non-chemical SPF protection makeup so
pure you can sleep in it and it actually
improves your skin over time
it's everything your skin needs and
nothing it doesn't for bare minerals to
be clean without compromise means good
for skin formulas with proven
performance like every bare minerals
product it's 100% cruelty free better
yet both the original and matte loose
powder foundations are available in 30
shades upgrade to clean beauty products
use the foundation finder at bare
minerals calm to find your perfect match
first time customers will get 15% off
when you use promo code not too deep
that's bare minerals calm promo code not
too deep for 15% off your first purchase
bare minerals the power of good this
episode matcha deep is brought to you by
lola if we care about the ingredients in
the food we eat and the beauty products
we use why shouldn't we feel the same
way of our feminine care products the
fda doesn't require brands to disclose a
comprehensive list of ingredients in
their feminine care products so most of
them don't but lola offers complete
transparency about the ingredients found
in their tampons pads liners and wipes
all of which are 100% organic cotton
with no added chemicals fragrances
synthetics or dyes plus with lois
customizable subscription you get to
choose your mix of products mix of
absorbency number of boxes and frequency
of delivery and you can even change skip
or cancel anytime this
is an absolutely wonderful company that
I never knew I needed they make it so
easy and personalized for every one of
you that chooses to use it it offers so
many different varieties and who knew
that you know the stuff that you're
putting up there should be more
transparent to you and now you get 40%
off all subscriptions by visiting my
Lola comm and enter grace 40 when you
subscribe that's my Lola comm and enter
grace 44 40 percent off all
subscriptions okay we're gonna do this
Twitter questions before we do gonna ask
you to two questions ask every single
guest that's on the podcast and the
first is who alive or dead would you
most want to throw cold spaghetti at
well Donald Trump yeah yeah no I changed
that Ivanka I'm not totally sure I think
we've had a couple people say her as of
late which is uh yeah I would like to
see that the other question ask every
guest is tell us your worst pants
[ __ ] story or like close call we can
only use three words or three small
phrases so like mine is college jogging
front lawn okay
yeah kayak Bahamas six a.m. I love when
everyone has an immediate story because
those are people that do not have
anything in their bank and I feel like
they're AI robots infiltrating the human
race okay well no follow-up questions 6
a.m. is a curious okay now we'll get
into these Twitter questions some want
to know who is the person you would most
want to be stranded on a desert island
with Bob Muller oh yeah I know you've
been a physical attraction yeah
currently actual yeah as soon as I get
my hands on outside if it's long term or
short term okay they also want to know
who would you least want to be stranded
with god I won't have to come up with
somebody that doesn't have anything to
do with Donald Trump hold up who would
at least want to be stranded with
somebody like a fat white man
[ __ ] fat guys that have like that
lower area that [ __ ] got the Bupa yeah
why is that how does that come into
action I don't know I saw I was at the
airport this weekend and there were two
men and then they both sat with their
like legs splayed wide open and it's
like now I understand why men are so
gross I never realized that they were
and now that you know all of our eyes
are open yeah I'm like oh yeah you guys
do think you can [ __ ] do whatever you
want the nuances of yeah men just doing
things that we took for granted so any
fat white guy defects played the white
man yeah guys fine I'm fine with that
someone to know does she feel like her
dogs are human and has she created a
voice or accent for them and they I
don't think my dogs are human because
they're really slow on the uptake for
sure what's their breed again there are
cha-cha mixes that makes it's okay so
they're mostly child and then apart
Rottweiler and parts wow they're thing
but there are real brother-sister and
they came with the names Bertrand and
Bernice so Bert Bertrand Bert is his
short for Bertrand Bertrand I can't even
really say that name and Bernice so when
I went up to this rescue in Northern
California and I'm like I she had chow
mixes there I wanted to you know get
more dogs yeah she was like oh I have a
brother and sister combo platter like
and I was like and she's like and their
names are Bert and Bernice I almost like
oh I max right there I was like hold on
a second I looked up with the sky was
like ah keep it together like actually
you seemed unstable I'm not gonna let
you take me you seem too eager for this
brother-sister those names are perfect
I thought you named them no I know
that's why I was like oh my god that's
totally a name I would give it yeah I've
always been hoping you have a Bernice in
my life let alone a Bert Bert Bert Bert
Bert you exactly Bert dot dot dot do you
follow any dog accounts on Instagram
yeah I do like insta dog I mean a bunch
I'll follow a lot of ciaochao pain how
did you get into Chow Chows uh well the
first rescue I had chunk I was told was
part Cho and for some stupid [ __ ]
reason I decided to believe them and he
wasn't a child and then Tammy was they
said was a child it was like 30% child
okay so finally I was like I believed I
love challenge because that's all I got
and it wasn't until after the fact that
I was like none of my dogs actually did
23andme for your dogs I found out the
truth yeah my assistant did the 23andme
for himself because he thought I said go
get your DNA tested someone to know how
does she balance feelings of anger
despair while taking on this new role of
public advocate yet still comedian which
is kind of a heavy question yeah this is
a mid you know the current political
climate yeah I just I think I'm I'm
right now I'm not in a political mindset
I don't want to hear about who's gonna
run what happen I wanted to really do
something for the midterms so and as
usual I threw myself in like you know
without ever thinking about it and so
I'm like kaput with politics right now
yeah I want to listen to the news I
don't give a [ __ ]
it's he stole a year of my life and he's
not stealing anymore no that's fair
that's super fair but also to yeah you
can dip in whenever you feel like you
want to go back in but it's a lot once
you do it I'll wait until there's an
election happening you know yeah as
otherwise everyday you're just exhausted
Oh a hundred percent it's too much to
even process someone snow what's your
weirdest drug related story hmm drug
related story would be was it the Iowa
probably the oh no actually I did
another drug the other few weeks ago
called mmm DMT 5 DM 5 Meo DMT something
like this is a frog serum that was weird
I didn't like that for a second what
someone has you basically just get
geometric in your head like everything
turns in you're supposed to have an
awakening I did not I was I felt
it's on drugs like everything I haven't
had a bad trip but yeah and I was like I
don't like this I don't like this I did
rip off all my clothes it's some sob
serum that everybody's doing I know this
[ __ ] town is ridiculous but I do like
to experience things every you know yeah
I think that I think it's healthy to
open your brain and different avenues
that might be closed off but for
something that may give a geometric
experience is very fun you just see like
geometric shapes and things whizzing by
you and like there's no like emotional
connection to go I think for a regular
person there would have been but I
wasn't prepared for what this was and
you know what I said I'd like whatever
one kept telling me about it and I had
like a three hours the middle of a day
and texted her in the morning so it
wasn't like it prepared oh yeah she said
sure I have an opening at 2:00 I was
like all right great I'll be there let
you do this with a guide yeah she was a
girl oh yeah she was a woman just like
made me smoke this thing and you know 40
minutes later you're fine yeah but
people had told me they had great
epiphanies and that did not happen for
me but I just don't think I was prepared
would you do it again
probably when I get to the epiphany
point but that's very funny I think that
there's I think there is a benefit and
just on a whim doing a drug like that
and not overthinking it too much because
yeah for someone else maybe that would
have opened them up a little bit okay
someone to know is there another talk
show or insight or comedy special yeah
maybe not talk show I can't do another
talk show but I don't know I'll do some
sort of special I just don't know if
it's I don't know what I'm gonna do
really yeah well I think that's great
you're just kind of saying yes and going
with the flow of the things that makes
yeah you got a great nose no stage yeah
yeah so once I know what's the hardest
part about writing life will be the
death of me uh crying in airports like
like you know having people constantly
come up to me in airports asking if I
was okay I'm like oh my god
okay says you're writing about sensitive
yeah I'd be writing about my mom dying
and what happened that we can like be
and
and I just be balling because it was so
cathartic that was the thing that was
the best lesson to write down your pain
like whether you're me or somebody who
wants to just like write it down for you
that process enough is just like getting
out some of your grief yeah regardless
of what you do with whatever you write
yeah well that's what they say the
artists way thing is like to write three
pages every morning and just like
whatever is good to your brain and just
get into that conditioned state of like
when I feel things I should put them on
paper and write you can figure out what
to do with them later when I start doing
that I'll get back to you and then I
also wonder what was the most fun part
of writing the book writing all the dog
chapters cuz they were so stupid and
funny that's really like kind of my you
know I just like to be really immature
and I am with my dogs and the way I
handle them and I'm a terrible parent
yeah but I have a very like unhealthy
because I sense I have no boundaries
I've grown up with no boundaries I you
know I decided where the boundaries are
when I decide sure and usually it's way
after the fact but with my dogs it's
just like you know I'm like it's like
the worst kind of parenting like I go in
so hard so hard so hard that they just
want to rebuff my advances and then they
you know I don't give them any space
because I'm not there that much right
there I'm like hey guys let's go like
I'm your parent you kind of not the au
pair that I think is just swinging by
but my cleaning lady throws it in my
face so it makes it hard for me to not
want to prove her wrong because she
knows they respect her more yeah she
feeds them and she plays with them yeah
I'm not gonna go to throw a tennis ball
in my backyard you want them to be smart
enough to understand that to learn how
to [ __ ] throw tennis ball themselves
is what I like to play catch that would
be a great life with each other great
special for Netflix someone to know
what's the best hangover cure to
excedrin yeah yeah is the best medicine
for hangovers really he's got caffeine
okay I didn't know that yeah um a lot of
people are asking this similar type of
question biggest thing she just
covered about herself during her year of
therapy that she didn't know before
that I had no empathy oh really
that was something that you that your
psychiatrist told you that you really
didn't think of before it never occurred
to me I thought sympathy like oh I'm
sympathetic he's like it's not the same
thing empathy is actually Matt not being
sympathetic and doing nice things for
people in need or whomever it's or
understanding that it's empathy is
actually really thinking about what it's
like to be that person and that doesn't
ever enter my mind I would just always
be like oh why doesn't everybody do it
this way why does everybody do that why
isn't everybody is interested in this as
I am like I didn't have any capacity and
so him telling me that I lacked it was a
huge obviously wake-up call and I was
like oh thank you that makes sense yeah
like it makes total sense and once you
realize what you're missing its able to
start to look out for it and kind of
build that muscle and go okay let me
think about what it's like to be that
person who's in the hospital instead of
just showing up repeatedly repeatedly
ruefully of bringing them food trying to
like ameliorate the situation actually
thinking about what that person is
unders is is going through is something
that I was lacking interesting but that
yeah that is a muscle that you have to
work on like I think everyone has to
work out and understand and like
recognize that because I think people do
think sympathy and empathy I think
that's the exact same thing that they're
two sides of the same coin when they're
a little bit different someone to know
how does she keep herself moving forward
what keeps her from saying okay this is
a safe space to stop right now say that
again what keeps you moving forward what
keeps you from saying to yourself okay
this is a safe spot to stop in terms of
like creative making shows your
documentary is that sort of thing I
think I think you just know you know you
know in your instinctively if something
is right for you or if it's wrong
yeah and you it's about sharpening that
skill and knowing like okay this is you
first of all you know you have growing
is evolving and motion and moving but
not in the alacrity you know that you're
gonna miss everything I think listening
to your gut is some
think that we you know I think it's a
lesson you think you learn and then you
[ __ ] do it again and you don't listen
to your gut and you have to learn the
[ __ ] lesson again and so for me it's
like you know as long as you're in a
space of like positivity and optimism
and hopefulness and generosity of spirit
and when you're having a conversation to
be paying really close attention to the
other person you're gonna know you're
gonna be so grounded and in touch with
everything you're gonna know when it's
time to move on and when it's time to
you know when you're out of your flow
state as you say like on Oprah
super-soul which I have listened to you
know like it's so true it's like you
know we all know when we're in the wrong
situation and we try to either convince
ourselves that you know of whatever or
we try and just put that noise that's
you know press it or admit and are too
afraid to admit that this is not right
right now
yeah yeah yeah I think creatively and
even in like maps over relationship
status stuff to you that like when
you're in a bad relationship with your
work or with a significant other
sometimes it's extremely hard to admit
it to yourself and so you convincing
yourself that maybe this is okay or you
repress that you even have to think
about that side of things
yeah I think that's really helpful
especially for like women in the
entertainment industry the idea of like
how do I move forward and how do I like
listen to my instincts as much and I
think there's more space for women to do
that now more than ever yeah and you're
one of those people occur like paving
the way for that it's almost no what are
you currently obsessed with do you watch
TV yeah yeah yeah I watched in star I'm
watching 10 star right now on Amazon
Prime it's with Tim Roth it's good it's
all sorts of [ __ ] up yeah I watch TV
I'm not obsessed I don't really obsess
about things yeah mmm I can't think of
anything maybe my dog's biggest fear
obstacle you had to overcome to get
where you are I don't fear obstacle you
know public speaking is horror oh yeah
yeah are you nervous about this tour
because it's not stand up because it's
more
no I feel less I feel no nurse because I
know that conversation is just the
easiest thing in the world yes where I
feel and it does and it matches what's
in the book you know the book is tough
for a stand-up tour about death because
although it's there's a lot of funny
subject matters that go along with death
it's like you know I think that it
matches the kind of tour I'm doing yes
so but yeah yeah I had a fear of public
speaking I just had to push push push
push through it I still don't like it I
still have people think it's easy for
such a public person who makes but yeah
I have highs and lows I mean I'm in a
good spot right now where I feel like I
have something to say I think the public
speaking when you don't have something
to say is what starts to creep on one's
nerves yeah 100% because you feel like a
fraud yeah what gives me the right to
stand up in front of these people and
say something that I don't even know
what I am saying right now yeah like a
point of view like you said with writing
this book write a book when you have
something to say when you have something
to put out there okay last question who
in the industry do you fangirl over
fangirl over or not even in the industry
can just be in the world oh god I don't
know fangirls there been anyone that
you've wanted to do an interview with or
talked to you that you haven't done yeah
I'm sure you get this question a million
times a day but yeah I don't know I
don't have a good answer for any of that
stuff I'm sorry no no worries I mean
these are the kinds of questions okay
here's my other question for you you go
and press for you do all these things
you do a million interviews you're gonna
talk about yourself in this story ten
thousand times a day all day long for
like the next few weeks what's the
question you hate getting us the most
before you go everyone that makes time
to be on that Judy but give them a
personalized fortune cookie for being
here so this is for you you can open it
and read what the innards have to say a
fortune it's um you know they're
questionable fortune cookies blue moon
there like a strong
I got oh my god this is gonna be so good
just make sure you don't edit this part
out no no you're wrong
Ivanka Trump well one day use your name
as one of her female empowered role
models and and you will get a burning
sensation in your anus when it happens
if you've already been feeling it lately
that's what it is yeah
wow what a fortune what a time to be
like such an non-traditional fortune and
it's like almost a paragraph it's yeah
we give full novels out we just want to
make sure that you know how to read is
what we do at the end of the podcast
take this home and tape it to Murphy but
just your your book life will be the
death of me is out now where can people
go buy it see you on tour you can go to
Live Nation com for tickets to my tour
I'll be coming to 20 cities around the
country and you can buy the book on any
of any of your local book sellers on at
random house com Barnes & Noble blah
blah blah Amazon anything you want
awesome thank you again for being here
this is super fun dude I'm so excited
for your tour and so excited for people
to read this book I think it'll resonate
with a lot of beautiful Souls and you're
just at Chelsea Handler across all
social media yes sweet okay we'll see
you guys next time on another episode of
not you deep goodbye 2deep 2deep 2deep
2deep again this episode of notch indeed
was brought you by Bare Minerals the
creators of clean beauty Bare Minerals
is driven by the philosophy that makeup
and skincare should make your skin
better not just better looking that's
why their best-selling original
foundation is made with only five
ingredients all minerals for bare
minerals to be clean without compromise
means good for skin formulas with proven
performance upgrade to clean beauty
products use the foundation finder at
bare minerals calm to find your perfect
match first time customers will get 15%
off when you use the promo code not too
deep bare minerals the power of good not
too deep is a production of grace helbig
incorporated producer and edited by
melissa demons
writing by diane kang a post-production
sound by christopher bell and an extra
special thanks to Flula for the theme
music
[Music]